23 stockwerke hoch ist die falcon heavy
die leistungsstärkste rakete der welt
am dienstag startete das prestige
projekt des privatunternehmen spacex
erfolgreich vom weltraumbahnhof cape
canaveral in florida zu einem testflug
an bord ein router tesla sportwagen der
tesla und space ex gründer elon musk
sprach von einem fast surreal moment das
war sagenhaft ich glaube ich habe noch
nie so etwas aufregendes gesehen
massa hatte vor dem testflug erklärt er
würde es als erfolg bezeichnen wenn die
rakete überhaupt in die luft ging ein
kritischer punkt war wenige minuten nach
dem abheben erreicht als sich die beiden
seiten triebwerke von der rakete lösten
und wieder zum weltraumbahnhof
zurückkehrten der staat ist ein
wichtiger meilenstein für max
unternehmen spacex bemüht sich unter
anderem um lukrative aufträge der us
weltraumbehörde nasa und des us-militärs
die falcon heavy soll durch
wiederverwendbare bauteile
kostengünstiger sein als andere raketen
die falcon heavy kann bis zu 70 tonnen
fracht in die erdumlaufbahn bringen
zu einem preis von 90 millionen dollar
pro start sie ist damit doppelt so
leistungsstark wie die bislang größte
rakete bei einem viertel der kosten auf
ihrem testflug soll die fackel heavy mit
ihrem tesla an bord die sonne umrunden